today's topic bill cosby
my man's gone free it's one of the few
times where he said hashtag
free cosby yeah and he got freed and got
free
so if you guys haven't heard already
bill cosby is out
after serving two years of what was
supposed to be a much longer sentence
he got out early because the supreme
court of pennsylvania i believe
overruled the decision and decided to
also
bar the prosecution from ever
prosecuting him again
which means he will not be going back to
jail for these crimes
and that is where we stand today he's
completely exonerated he is a free man
he's already made a few tv interviews
he's angry he feels like he was unjustly
done
so if you guys don't know what happened
cosby was charged with uh
weinsteining the lady basically how it
ended up happening was the previous d.a
the district attorney
made a deal with cosby in a civil suit
to get him to testify
and the deal was
that they wouldn't bring any criminal
charges against him if he testified
basically giving him immunity and this
also extended
to future dea's the new da comes
in says that deal isn't any good throw
it out
i'm gonna use a testimony where you
incriminated yourself
in this criminal trial and send him to
jail
which he spent two years in prison for
the supreme court decided that you can't
do that if you make a deal with someone
especially if you make them renounce
one of their rights which is the fifth
which is the fifth amendment right which
i think is like protection
yeah protection from like
self-incrimination right that you are
usurping the law and um the
understandings between
defendants and prosecutions so yeah
that's how it happened
so that's kind of like the gist of in
the technicalities
he's a free man in the days 83 i'd
highly doubt they're gonna bring another
case against him he has a few more years
it's a wrap for him
um did he get away with it yeah he did
like a lot of powerful influential men a
lot of them get away with their crimes
you know that's kind of the norm the
other days is his legacy was destroyed
whether he got released or not they have
him admitting to these crimes already
even if it's in civil suit they haven't
admitting to it so he's done this
this wasn't course this wasn't forced he
admitted to this
because he did do this as far as bill
cosby's legacy he's going to be seen
for those acts everything else most of
it's going to get erased
so there's no silver lining here i don't
think this is a great ending or anything
like that
it's just the reality of the situation
um
so those are pretty much my thoughts you
know what worked in bill's benefit
the fact that he worked alone
because if he was like jeffrey epstein
he was working with a bunch of people
doing all that stuff as a group
bill would have never made it out oh
they would have flipped no he
he would have never made that alive they
would have got him oh yeah because
they're not gonna let you ride on
the rich [ __ ] look at bill gates he's
like being associated with like
the [ __ ] prince of like what country
i never heard of yeah you know something
i'm like worked alone you know what i
mean it was him
spanish fly was bad for a spanish girl
right so
it worked out pretty well for him
quaaludes yeah
sometimes teamwork is not the best one
that's all i'm saying you got that right
so if you go to a crime try not to
involve a bunch of people
and when i heard he got released i was
just like
after this pandemic i'll believe
anything but what did you expect
i said what was done of course i was
like yeah sure of course i was gonna die
in jail
you thought she was in jail for two
years you don't really think something's
gonna get overturned it's not like i
followed the case that yeah that's what
you're saying so
yeah so yeah that much oh yeah um
appeals are generally not that
successful
and now exactly when you stop following
when he said that he did it once he went
to jail what
when he was he did it i mean that was
man yeah
so you know the thing about bill i think
the thing about bill that i've always
hated was like he was
always telling people to be uptight and
to be correct and polite and all this
stuff and
find out behind closed door he thought
it was hilarious to put women to bed and
bang him
in a pudding pudding preach what are
your thoughts
my thoughts are well first and foremost
the first thing that you have to
understand is that it's not because he's
free that is not guilty you understand
what i'm saying
oj it's really just because basically
the da [ __ ] up
the d.a messed up pretty bad
he's shipping someone from their rights
their fundamental rights
in the constitution of the united states
of americas
you mess up so the person that did the
disservice to
all the women is the d8 that's what
happened the one that you know no let me
go against that it's easily overthrown
that's you you gave that man a case the
first d.a that gave that deal
i don't even know really understand what
the deal was to you know try to give
that deal because
if he was just to say yeah i did this
and i did that and i did that whatever
what not
but you know we're not gonna incriminate
yourself it's just basically
i understand how these ladies might have
felt like i was a dangerous to their
life or whatever what not
and that's basically a slap on the wrist
or whatever well the thing is they
didn't have much of a case against him
without his testimony
the reason why the second d.a was able
to convict him because he testified
and admitted to stuff i was just talking
about the first d8 so so the reason why
the first deal made that deal who's like
i can't get him on anything so let me at
least get him to admit this so there
might be a civil suit that'll work out
so i think that was but i will say
generally immunity deals like this are
not given for these kind of crimes
generally they're reserved
for white-collar crimes you know things
like tax fraud
or things like um collusion
yeah or stock exchange stuff like you
know those kind of crimes that's when
you get immunity for you know
giving a testimony or whatever but you
know for criminal cases it's not very
common that you get this kind of stuff
the last case where this kind of thing
happened
funny enough was jeffrey epstein back in
like 2007.
if you aren't aware jeffrey epstein was
initially charged
with you know following girls that was
reduced to the craziest sentence you
could imagine
he had to do like one year in jail but
it wasn't when you're in jail he would
go to jail during the day
yeah and go home at night yeah
which is so the only correlation between
the two is that they're very powerful
influential men and they seem to have
gotten off lightly
now basically it's just like what
happened to oj it's not because
the glove didn't fit and uh it's not
because the lapd didn't you know
tempered with the evidence that it
didn't happen you know what i mean
you know they have term for that it's
called fruit of the poisonous tree
mm-hmm right because if you get items
from someone's house without a warrant
yeah that stuff gets excluded from the
case yeah
because the fact that your procedures
weren't accurate so
to allow that in is to reward people who
break procedures
but also but also there was things that
was evidence that were planted
right right on top of that but that's
criminal but yeah anyways all that to
say yeah absolutely
like you're saying you know there's a
funny there's a funny uh conspiracy
theory about oj
that actually oj didn't do it but he was
actually involved and it was this kid
that did it and that's why the glove
didn't fit
so j and oj and the the long chains that
happened with the the
the lapd was to for the
the long term that happened with the
lapd was for the kid to be able to throw
out the evidence
it's funny story but whatever went up
that's my face when i watched alex jones
laughing yeah yeah i'm laughing because
he's hilarious
carry on yeah but that's pretty much it
i mean you
you messed up you could have left it
alone like that and there was nothing
you could have done better than that
than what was happening there
and looking now now you had a whole
bunch of people pissed and you got this
guy free
he would have been free you just really
wanted him in jail but
you you didn't have much of a case not a
big fan but
that's my thoughts on him anything else
no well then what do you guys think
about this whole bill cosby thing
are you glad are you upset do you guys
agree disagree
you wanna hear your thoughts
[Music]
i'd be the one that keeps you